after a long day of hiking you need to
unwind how you ask a massage a massage
is a feat by sturdy Chinese men who
don't give a [ __ ] about you one thing I
love about the Monterey Park area is
there's a lot of cheap places where you
can get dope massages now one of the
issues that you might run into is that
the people who do administer these
massages don't really speak English the
great thing is Mariel that you guys
don't know is actually a Quadra lingual
she speaks English Japanese Chinese and
Korea chinese specifically uh mandarin
so it kind of worked out for us in that
and that kind of sense because she was
allowed to communicate with these dudes
very well they allowed us to film
because of her skills yes so the place
that we went to they the upstairs area
anyways they specialize in like foot
massages particularly shutting my feet
so I really didn't know how this was
gonna go down but people told me that
when you get a foot massage it's
different than when you actually get
tickled so he started it off by dipping
my feet in boiling soup water which was
great by the way
when I get a massage I don't know what I
don't know this is a lot of people but I
prefer getting massaged by old woman is
that just me but we didn't have that
choice we kept three elderly Chinese men
that we're gonna do it which is
perfectly fine I think I think old men
are skilled which means that they've
done it for many years so I was
completely okay with that then know who
I was gonna get but they seemed very uh
at at what they're doing I tell you if
you guys never had a head massage you
should get one that's pretty crazy
for a moment dinner for that that a guy
was touching me that's when you know the
massage just could just like huh
I'm falling in love with almost like she
was funny like when you get a massage
and you get massaged by Amanda looks
like you in the future you feel like
that's what it was it was me in the
future
I was like what the [ __ ] are you my
father
ever saw stride nothing left so hard
it's like the massage is overpowering
too ticklish take a limit the tickly I
know so there's now mind you when you
get an Asian massage understand that
it's not like that
uh yeah type of massage that you see
like that why people get I think they
deal with something called acupressure
so they're hitting certain like parts of
your feet that are supposed to affect
another part of your body that helps you
but laughs and the kind of like releases
the tension in your muscles so it is
gonna hurt a little bit but there's a
purpose to it
it's about pain now feel good later
Asian massages it's just exactly
representative of a tub Asian culture
your pairs beat you now so you end up
being a doctor later big which are they
getting much than that's nothing I think
I'm a terrible boyfriend because
whenever something bad happens to Mariel
it makes the first thing I do is laugh
it just it's funny to me
so like you know you expect she'll she
was the one who wanted the massage but
as she was getting it I don't know
what's going on they're speaking to each
other in Mandarin but she's in a lot of
pain and he's making me it makes me
happy that she's hurting now I don't
think she enjoyed me laughing at her
because once again I don't speak
Mandarin so I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened but she kind of looked at me
with this evil stare she says something
in Mandarin
my guy who's massaging my feet starts to
laugh then I'm an excruciating pain so
she said something I don't know what the
[ __ ] it was but that man was massaging
my soul I didn't do it on purpose just a
little pressure I don't think they
understood what stop it hurts memes
because as I was in more pain screening
he did it more wood this is a language
barrier thing or he thought he was a
funny guy
I don't know but [ __ ] him
it's so strong this is why you never
mess with your girlfriend especially
when she's the only one that can speak
the language of the people that are
doing things to you he's so strong
thank you there was some hell to get to
here's the funny thing so he was
massaging my back right which it felt
great but the whipping is when your head
is in that massage table you can only
imagine what they're doing to you as
they're giving you that massage so I
felt these elbows from my shoulder blade
all the way down to my lower back now in
my mind I'm like how is he doing this
what what position is his body hit and
it only clicked to me later on because I
felt warmth on the back of my neck I was
like oh he must have like a hot towel
there it wasn't a hot towel the guy had
his ball sack on the back of my head he
was rowing back and forth from my
shoulder blade through my lower back
he basically tea-bagged the [ __ ] out of
me so there's three guys and out of all
three of them I got the tea bag master I
think it's only his technique he wasn't
doing that to other people I was the
only one they got TV great though
there's a very strong man very sure what
was happening but I'm almost 100% sure I
thought the ball sack over my head I was
like what what in his body is he putting
me at and how is he reaching there
that's a ball go ahead
last time I came here same Kyle's in a
private room and so were you clothed or
not happen that club has had underwear
hunt and then he put his knees my
ballsack what was what was I was like
fast if he is elbows but how was he
getting his elbows from their head and I
was like there's fabric on my head style
I think she's a gang leader I think
those were like her homies that is not
what you said you said something evil I
didn't know all I thought was him giggle
that he started it was perfect the way
it was I know it you should have left it
at that I think when you go to a beach
to a massage place just know that there
is gonna be some pain but there is
relief on the other side you just got to
be strong enough to endure it what I
like about this place number one they
don't teach you one time number two they
have a sense of humor number three they
do really good worse I mean this is my
first time here and and they're really
cheap by the way that that one hour
massage was twenty bucks and on average
wouldn't you know some people pay on a
meal
so that's relief for the whole week for
twenty dollars I'm pretty sure every now
and that you guys can spend it on that
but expect to be a little bit of pain or
just don't get a girlfriend that says
secret languages to them to hurt you
thank you happy massage spa it was
awesome
those are fantastic